DANNY: An old Mercedes
there to the right.
You know I love those.
I got one-- don't
need another one.
RYAN: Corvair wagon.
DANNY: We are not
doing a Corvair wagon.
I don't care.
RYAN: What's this on the left?
Chevy--
DANNY: '53, '54?
RYAN: Yeah.
DANNY: You got to take
four inches off the front,
and six inches off the back.
RYAN: Yeah, that is
gonna be a lot of money.
DANNY: Right.
- OK.
Dude, I'm sorry.
It's a Checker.
RYAN: Get out of here.
DANNY: It's a wagon.
RYAN: It's a limo!
DANNY: It's a--
[laughs]
I'm not buying this.
I just have to know
the story on this one.
I just-- I can't resist.
I just gotta know.
NANCY: Hello?
- Hey, how you doing?
We're car guys.
We caught a glimpse of this
very interesting vehicle
as we were driving
by and just wanted
to get the story on that thing.
NANCY: Actually, my husband
should be home in, like,
hopefully any minute now.
DANNY: Oh, OK.
NANCY: Oh, there's my husband.
I'm Nancy.
DANNY: Welcome home!
- I'm Ryan.
- Ryan?
Nice to meet you.
- I'm Danny.
Danny, nice to meet you.
- You are?
- Phil.
Phil.
I hope you don't mind us
bugging you for a minute.
But we were driving by, and
we gotta know the story.
Do you have a few minutes?
Do you mind?
PHIL: Absolutely.
DANNY: It's cool, man.
The iconic Checker
taxi cabs could
be seen rolling
American city streets
for much of the 20th century.
The company was founded in
1921 when Morris Markin, who
had been running cabs in an
auto body shop in Chicago,
loaned $15,000 to a friend with
a car manufacturing business.
Markin eventually absorbed
his friend's company,
and Checker Cab
Manufacturing was born.
While for much of their
history this Kalamazoo based
manufacturer produced only
commercial taxis and airport
shuttles like this
one, in the late 1950s,
they introduced two
passenger cars--
the Superba and the
Marathon-- both of which
continued production
up until the company
stopped all production in 1982.
First off, what year is it?
PHIL: '69.
OK.
And it is a Checker?
- Absolutely.
And why, and when, and what
did they do all of this to it?
Well, my dad was Air Force.
DANNY: Military man?
PHIL: Yes.
So we traveled a lot.
DANNY: Well, God bless
him for his service.
So we travelled
cross country, had
six children in
the family, so he
needed a car to hold them all.
- Your dad bought this--
- Yeah.
--brand new?
Flew to Kalamazoo, drove
it off the assembly line.
- No way.
- So this was the family ride?
So this was the
private, family car?
PHIL: Absolutely.
When was the last
time this car ran?
The last on the road
was probably 30 years ago.
DANNY: 30 years she's
been sitting there?
PHIL: Yeah.
DANNY: Wow.
My understanding is
everything was stock
except the fact that
he put the brakes
from the [inaudible] on it.
DANNY: Do you mind if
I just take a peek?
PHIL: No, not at all.
Did you see how big the back
door is from the front door?
The front door is
still kind of small,
and all the back
doors-- oh, wow.
PHIL: We used to--
when we travelled,
we'd sit on the floor
and color on the seat.
RYAN: Look how
much room there is.
It's huge.
PHIL: And when we
did field trips
when I was in,
like, second grade,
they'd say, how many
kids can you take?
My mom would send a note,
yeah, we can take, like, 18.
[laughs]
DANNY: Is there an
engine in there?
Oh, yeah.
Can we take a peek?
PHIL: Please.
Yeah.
Wow.
RYAN: Plain Jane 351.
Oh, it's a Target Master.
It's a replace--
it's a replacement.
Yeah.
I would be curious as
to what-- what would
it take to buy this car?
I am-- I'm just curious.
Five to eight years
ago, maybe, I was
talking to a guy in California.
And he said, probably, he could
find a buyer for about $5,000
as it is.
DANNY: As is?
Yeah.
- As it is.
DANNY: Gotcha.
This thing is cool.
You rock.
Appreciate it.
We'll talk to you
again, I'm sure.
All right, take care.
DANNY: You rock, bro.